plants are the foundation for all life
understanding plant diversity is
critical to our continued survival
the goal of the world flora online is to
accumulate in one place on a website a
description and illustrations of every
known plant species
we are about five years into the process
we are accumulating new specimens we're
digitizing them and all of that
information feeds in ultimately to the
world floor online
the main way that our specimens come to
us is that they are collected in the
field
when they're here they are mounted onto
stiff paper
the information about the plant is
transcribed onto a little label that
goes along with the specimen
a good mounter can do about 50 specimens
per day
once the specimens are mounted we
photograph them
then that information goes online pretty
much immediately
the project began in 2010 and it is
meant to be completed by 2020.
we've photographed
about 2.6 million of our specimens
worldwide it must be on the order of 10
or 15 million
plants are endlessly fascinating and we
have to know what they are and how they
differ from one another in order to
understand what kind of measures need to
be taken to protect them
you